hello and welcome to this video this is
a new 2510 game here on the icy yes I'm
still doing them only been quite a while
it's still tricky to get opponents and
it's not a very popular pool it seems
okay um we got to see three Sicilian I I
went d 5 and 25 mostly but I didn't fare
so well in those games in blitz games
that is and now I'm trying something
else even though I have to admit that
i'm not a huge expert here Bishop c4 I
guess these sixes I could move pretty
much regardless what white is doing here
d for Bishop c4 I have to attack the
pawn them T for looks maybe normal now
yeah sometimes you also have weird
things happening in this boy I had a
game earlier today we're after nine
minutes of playing the guys sunday
disconnected yeah this is great you have
a nine minute video kind of in the
middle of a game and then they
disconnect which is pretty much useless
to upload but so you've wasted like nine
minutes and fear rather stupid because
you have to twit do it all over again
with a new game ok mr. tick tick tock is
he going to do default looks very normal
there I mean okay you can take on d6 as
well that probably also should be quite
ok an interesting question is if Bishop
takes d5 is worth considering but the
bishop it's probably a bit too strong a
piece to give up that early against the
night ok yeah that's an interesting
question I want to take only five or not
or just 96 I think 96 I want to develop
quickly here takes Knight takes bishop
t6 is an interesting idea trying to
attack the night there quickly but well
this way I think he will very likely
capture on d6 walk him he can 74 of
course
yeah maybe also rookie one okay he gives
me the bishops if you know me you know
that I'm happy about that but this is a
pretty normal thing that stronger
players do them prefer the ships in most
cases they are the better piece okay
what about this Bishop d6 rookie 1b
should be six hmm yeah i guess i have to
take it anyway so the sorry about that
and now he goes deform so he just gives
me the bishop and then opens the
position while KD form is kind of a
thought rook e1 at least to irritate me
a bit of it okay going to go into Castle
here that's an interesting interesting
moment I can take on d4 I can play C for
both Musa make quite some sense see
takes d4 because it opens up the
position and probably will get him to
move the noid
something like CD 494 queen h4 for
example is a rather interesting idea
trying to provoke g3 queen age 3
intending bishop HP it doesn't have a
light squared Bishop so however if I
take and he takes with the pawn well
it's very solid of course ma'am i think
i'm going to replace you for i'm really
not sure about it but i think it
probably keeps a little bit more tension
in the position t King see takes and
then 93 mmm that was actually a somewhat
interesting moment because at this
moment he had to be three where I would
have been basically forced to capture
and now I can't play b3 b5 if I like
okay I'm going to enter here
new bishop just look quite nice there on
the light squares even though it doesn't
attack anything so it's not necessarily
that brilliant apiece yeah I think v3
looks very young normal let's say very
standard but there are some ideas even
Bishop a three years not entirely stupid
at least it seems like that first glance
and head yes but should be to trapping
the rook bc forbes should be too cd5
yeah it wins they exchange this this
whole procedure Redskins it's rather
interesting visual a three in some cases
also very helpful that the a pawn is
blocked so be three maybe I really do
bishop I III don't not see why not hmm
anyway okay what tortoise is supposed to
do besides be three I mean you can play
like rookie won some something
non-committal I have a couple of easy
moves that I can play here like be 5 a-5
f6 moves that improve my position a
little bit taking some squares expanding
it's not so easy for Wyatt because its
lack of space this is why b3 and such a
standard procedure to get some space
even though yeah Bishop e3 as I said
it's kind of annoying I think I wonder
it can actually flick in Bishop d3 here
right yeah this is not a bad idea let's
do this covering this I wanted to okay
so he actually would be willing to
sacrifice and exchange
no but I don't have to take it on I can
take with the pawn yet simply and keep
my advantages Bishop f1 I didn't I
didn't like that much giving him the two
points that this just keeps very good
control and if he goes rookie one Bishop
a3 is a very awkward moved to face I
really don't see a good reply against
that to be honest I don't see it pieces
are quite badly coordinated another
purely strategically strategic idea
would be 9725 or in case of rookie one
which seems very likely to happen no
it's not doing that it seems he wants to
sacrifice the exchange really but I can
go a 6cm and go be five to win a piece
if he takes e4 this is actually pretty
strong I belief kicks the Queen away and
that's still left let's say let's say he
goes I go a6 he plays rookie one or
something I played b5 Queen has to go
all the way back and then quit a5 is
very awkward very awkward c3 is hanging
and hard to defend and still Bishop e3
is there yeah so 86 is good you know
covers against Knight c4 due to the b5
fork his playing is interestingly like
in the giving away the exchange here is
a good fight but i think i'm not taking
and just going for this year's stronger
that grabbing material
this is funny app what about the Queen
tick-tock your queen help all right
reserved yeah he made a plate for a self
trap here off the Queen yea rather short
game but it had some some good
interesting moments that's let's go back
yeah so this is certainly a normal
position and here g-form is some very
likely to lead to some main line this
for example is a main line that I when I
know that it is a main line but it would
really know how it is continued from
here pretty normal self but he captured
and I really don't like it this is some
giving away the bishop a very early on
and it's really not a clear compensation
for him he's not better developed or I
don't have weaknesses or whatever and if
nothing special is happening then the
bishop pair constitutes a pretty serious
thing I thought you should go he won him
to at least try to to pin me here so
that's after that after deform I might
have to worry about this move for
example no I feel okay yeah i mean for
example i can take take and even cancel
him and because well he cannot grab he
an assessor i cannot take on h2 here
let's check maybe this is just a drunk
check hmm i don't get the king in now
yeah it's a draw and if i go Queen age
for immediately then g3 and tons of
stuff is hanging so it's not working the
engine wants to do this trapping the
rook yeah really traps the Roku be funny
yeah okay you went d4 and I just was
happy to Castle quickly so I don't need
to play Bishop e6 you went here yeah now
this is the choice I could also have to
take in here but I didn't like that so
much Knight takes Queen age for looks
pretty
directive something like this for
example intending Bishop g4 that looks
really good but I felt he could take
maybe with the pawn and then play 93
which is of course okay for black but I
wasn't quite sure if this is better or
the advance I'd like to keep more things
on the board so this and he went 92 yeah
he could have played me through here
because now be 5a for I don't have a six
the engine actually points out that
before as a playable move i have to
agree em that's probably right I didn't
think about that okay now he played b3
and really hmm I'm i don't really like
that went here and he doubt tried to two
sec they exchanged yeah if he goes rupee
one i have this nice choice between
Bishop e3 and queen 85 and thought this
is good not interesting very interesting
when the engine wants to go and Group B
1 here and actually claims that this is
kind of playable okay now it just
adjusts the assessment that gives black
an advantage yeah it looks awkward
really Bishop a three but I also felt
between 8-5 should be pretty okay if he
takes now again this is really awkward
and he cannot play Queen a 4 i'm
covering that okay you tried this if I
know it take here Queen have one and
down let's say it takes cakes I'm
material up but I think those two pawns
at least provide some central and
control and I wanted to keep or
everything in hand
each ride this move yeah I think if he
goes rookie won again I have Queen 85
and I don't see how he covers that note
that this is really awkward so we went
here and after this after a six I'm just
clearly better already rook t1 was was a
funny self trap but if he does this for
example I'm going here back and he just
has lost time giving me those moves and
now Bishop e3 and he's probably not able
to prevent we should be to winning the
exchange there okay well thanks for
watching